[Music]
thank you
good morning the top stories from Sky
News live in the city food inflation in
the UK slows but is still up more than
15 percent on the year
Asda to acquire petrol station operator
EG groups UK and Ireland business in a
2.3 billion pound deal it'll be I'll be
speaking to the as the chairman Lord
rose
the United States edges nearer to a deal
to raise its debt ceiling
plus looking for a strike I'll be
speaking to the chief executive of
Hollywood Bowl about the UK's 10-pin
Revival
[Music]
a very good morning to you this is Ian
King live with me Wilfred Frost the now
of business and economic news from the
heart of the city now there are hopes
that food inflation in the UK might have
peaked following months of price hikes
squeezing household budgets
research by the British retail
Consortium and Nielsen shows a 15.4
percent rise in food inflation in the
year to May it's the second fastest
annual increase that the BRC has ever
measured but it is down slightly from
April's record-breaking increase of 15.7
it means that someone who spent around
20 pounds in a food shop a year ago
would now be paying a little over 23
pounds for the same basket of goods
overall shop price inflation Rose from
8.8 percent to nine percent between
April and May according to the BRC which
is an all-time high well in a moment
we'll hear what the as the chairman Lord
rose has to say about food inflation
I've just been speaking to him moments
ago about the news that as the group is
to acquire the petrol station operator
EG groups UK and Island business
creating a company with combined
revenues of nearly 30 billion pounds
it's a story that was broken by Sky News
last week by our city editor mark
kleiman the 2.27 billion pound deal will
mean the acquisition of around 350
petrol stations and more than a thousand
Food To Go locations Lord rose says the
deal will bring us this Heritage to even
more communities in the UK and I began
by asking him what exactly he meant by
that
we're going to create a an omni-channel
retail champion in the UK and we're
going to be number two effectively in
the UK grocery Market uh we're gonna
have a business which is going to have
around 29 billion pound of turnover
we're going to have around 1800 sites
we're going to have a business which
will allow us to extend the Asda brand
to a wider Community than we currently
can do mostly because we're going to
have food service and we're going to
have convenience which we haven't had in
strength in there as the business of the
food it's interesting that you mentioned
nearly 2 000 sites I mean much of the
last decade the debate in groceries was
around online uh food sales something
you know a lot about given your your
prior chairmanship of ocado is the
pendulum swinging back more to
traditional retail than it has done for
for the last 15 years or so
well I think the key word there well
Brittany is Omni Channel today if you're
going to be somebody who's compete in
this very competitive world that we
compete in you've got to be able to
touch all places so we have to give
customers what they want where they want
how they want it and we will do that so
we will do it in petrol for court
stations we will do it through
convenience we will do it through our
online deliveries we'll do it in our
convenience stores in our supermarkets
in our Hypermarket
I I read through the press release uh in
detail your comments comments of your of
your very various colleagues throughout
the business what's not mentioned uh is
the deposition of of the company uh is
it fair to say that that was a driving
force behind the the deal as well that
it might give the combined business a
better chance to refinance given that
rates have rised and what is overall a
very leveraged business still
the main reason that we have done this
deal is one that we have been looking at
for some time is that when uh we took
over the Asda business some 18 months
two years ago we knew that we had some
massive strengths but we knew we had
some opportunities to build on for that
and that was the convenience part of our
business you'll ever recall that uh some
months ago a while back we acquired 119
sites from the co-op and we've now hired
we've now acquired or will acquire
another number of sites which will allow
us to extend our convenience business uh
now the the when you talk about the
depth position the debt position in
terms of Leverage in as they won't
materially change going forward
but but this uh this will allow you a
benefit of the deal is a hope that
you'll be able to refinance some of the
debt from EG now across the combined
business
well it is true to say that in in doing
this transaction it will uh allow EG to
delever a little bit at some point in
time but the primary purpose of today
and what's Driven today in our strategic
direction today is about driving as the
business when we walk out of the
business back in 2021 we were ambitious
to become for instance number two in the
retail sector in the UK we are currently
number three and we're ambitious to be
number two doing what we're doing today
will allow us to be able to get onto
that roadmap and get and move on in that
direction let's touch a little bit about
the outlook for uh food prices here in
the UK it's been a hot topic of course
do you think the worst of the food price
inflation has been and gone or is there
their higher rates of inflation still to
come
well I'm hopeful that we are at the peak
and then that we will steadily see
decline now but you know we certainly
haven't been able to see the quick
declines that were speculated on earlier
in the year well you know it's a very
complicated situation uh causing this
this inflationary situation but I must
say not just asthma all retailers
Wilfred are very very efficient we are a
very efficient industry so in real terms
the cost of food the cost of clothing
and the cost of electronics has come
down over the last 20 30 40 years
largely due to the efficiency of
retailers and governments of any
complexion oh I was a debt of gratitude
and this recent uh you know speculation
over the last couple of days about uh
you know fixing prices it's frankly you
know this is the rather backward looking
it reminds me of a man of a certain age
and the prices of incomes policy that we
used to have in the late 60s let's touch
on that a little bit but it's clearly an
argument was made successfully made that
uh the oil and gas Majors uh did deserve
to pay a one-off winfall tax why do food
retailers not deserve either to see
price controls or face a windfill tax
well let's just take this very simply
look at the look at the profit margins
of food retailers and look at the profit
margins of the energy people over the
last 18 months and the answer will be
very clear you know the retailers make
between three and four percent margin
that's what they make and that's you
know that that if you took to compare
that against margin was made by other
Industries and let's take the energy
industry that's a completely different
that's comparing an apple and a pair
we're in a very efficient industry and
we are very competitive and you know
with a number of outlets that we've got
here now the consumer has got massive
Choice uh and uh and in real terms
fantastic value for money no it's
definitely a fair point low single digit
profit margins uh clearly is is not as
excessive as some businesses I guess the
question uh for for here and this year
ahead when there's clearly cost of
living pressures uh we can't see with
Asda because it's not publicly listed
that the detail that you can see in
other margins would you and do you think
your colleagues at other big food
retailers pledge not to increase that
margin during this this tricky time for
consumers
we've all lent in look at the profit
results that were produced by our
competitors and ourselves most retailers
or grocery retailers profits over the
last year have gone backwards whether
you're talking about Tesco whether
you're talking about Sainsbury's whether
you're talking about Asda they've all
gone backwards we as an industry have
lent in and done some very very good
work in making sure our customers get
great prices we had an operation well
ahead of the government's proposal last
week about locking prices down which we
call dropped a lot where we fixed prices
for nearly a year at the beginning of
2022 so we're very active in making sure
we sell close to stay close to our
customers and give them the deals that
they expect but it's tough because if
you look at commodity prices as they
come through for all the reasons we know
they've been going up whether it's raw
material prices whether it's oil whether
it's wheat whether it's uh butter fats
you know we've seen massive increases
your question earlier was uh have we
reached the preaker that I would hope so
and you know going forward into 2024
let's hope that we've reach better times
I'm just touching on fuel retail prices
uh petrol prices as well something that
of course you're heavily involved with
too someone in the eye of the storm here
in terms of your exposures the CMA
recently reported that at least one
supermarket has significantly increased
its internal forward-looking margin
targets over this period though
speculation they they were referring to
you is it unfair though to look at uh
Asda and EG's relative price increases
of fuel as opposed to the absolute
because on absolute levels you're fairly
low and you're starting from a point
where prior owners Walmart the US owners
wanted to drive footfall into the stores
and make a loss with fuel retail well
just talk us through some some of your
current pricing and thinking on that
we were and have been for many years the
price leader amongst the big four
supermarkets we are currently the prize
lever amongst the four supermarkets we
are committed to be the price leader
amongst the four supermarkets full stop
fair enough so that that might though
mean ongoing percentage increases but in
absolute levels you you'll uh you'll
maintain your your price leadership
we will be the cheapest amongst the Big
Four
fair enough um so so just uh coming back
to the the bigger picture uh Lord rose
do you understand the predicament the
government faces when it has to weigh up
whether to impose price controls whether
it has to weigh up to impose windfall
taxes or would it be a terrible error
for the long-term future of British
business if the government pushed
further than it has done already more
than just rhetoric uh into the food
retail space to try and uh impose some
price limits
listen I'm not an economist but I'm a
businessman I've been in business for 50
years you can't interfere with Market
forces at the end of the day you have to
trust us as retailers to give our
consumers the best deals our customers
are very Savvy they're very smart they
know that we're working hard to do
things on their behalf we will continue
to do so intervention it always brings
in unintended consequences and
personally I would not recommend it
Lord rose uh there on the topic of food
inflation it's just the worst of it
might uh well be behind us that as the
chairman there on the day that they
announced a 2.3 billion deal with eg
groups UK and Ireland Assets Now moving
on after weeks of political acrimony
Congress will finally vote tomorrow on
the fiscal responsibility act to raise
the United States debt ceiling and
prevent a fast approaching default
President Biden and the Republican house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy agreed a deal
late on Saturday night that if it's
approved we'll allow the federal
government to continue to borrow money
I'm joined Now by Morris Reid a partner
at the global consulting firm uh actim
Morris great scene good morning good
good to see you here in in person in
London as well so so first step how
significant in the process of extending
the debt deadline is it that there's a
deal between the two main protagonists
McCarthy and Biden versus still needing
to get through Congress could it still
fall apart in Congress sure absolutely
you have both wings of the parties that
are not crazy about this but as you look
at Macar Dorothy I think if you look
from the perspective of him versus Biden
he's clearly the winner Biden the White
House underestimated his ability to push
this type of package through his caucus
he did it and then he had the backing
out of just a caucus but also the Senate
Republicans who are saying listen Barton
you have to deal with him we'll we'll
deal with this once you've passed it so
I think he is if you look at the two
guys I think he's the winner so far
interesting and so just talk about going
through Congress because I guess there
hasn't been as loud criticism only over
the last 48 hours for many Democratic
members but the the sort of Freedom
caucuses it's referred to often that
contains a lot of supporters of the
former president Trump within the
Republican party they don't like this
deal so might Republicans not back it
well you'll have those guys who will
never back anything because they're
Donald Trump supporters and they want to
make sure that Donald Trump wins
everything so expect that noise I think
that his caucus will stay fast on the
Democratic side you're starting to hear
Democrats are upset that Biden actually
mishandled this they wanted to run out
clock it actually worked against them so
you'll start to see more Democrats
particularly the far left Democrats
starting to complain that this is going
to hurt their constituency groups the
way bidens handled this but there's
enough in the middle for the deal course
of course this is also where Biden's
going to say that he's a middle of the
road he's a pragmatist he works at both
sides but you'll see a lot of squawking
and noise on both sides so just talk us
through why you're saying that this has
been a better negotiation on the part of
of McCarthy on the Republican side than
Biden because you could look at it and
say that the the cuts to spending are
marginal much less so than say when a
bomber in 2011 faced a similar threat
why is this a a win for McCarthy and and
the Republicans so two things number one
McCarthy the way he came into office no
one expected him to have the authority
or the backing of the caucus given it
took so long to become speaker right
that's number one number two once he got
that package through he called the White
House Bluff they didn't expect him to
get it done once he got it done he had
the force the momentum behind him to to
stand toe-to-toe with the president as
you originally remember Biden met with
the big four and then went to the big
two then they went to the speaker and
the speaker Rose to the occasion instead
of shrinking in a moment so he I believe
will be a net positive on this regard
Biden just wants to get this done right
frankly he needs to pass him so he can
start to focus on reelection you'll see
this can move very quickly to the
presidential conversation because Trump
will jump on this no matter what so just
interesting you mentioned that the Biden
will perhaps lean on the fact that he's
he's doing a sort of cross-party deal
here and that he deserves credit for
that what does it say about the prospect
of major legislation between now and the
next Presidential it's just very
interesting you mentioned that because
this will embolden the Republicans to
block Biden they see this as an
opportunity where they've been able to
hold the caucus together push back on
the president so I expect that the
president will move a set of a
legislative agenda to a Rose Garden
agenda if you remember what we deal with
Ben Clinton when we were in the office
you just started to run things from the
Rose Garden you start to use the exact
executive privilege instead of trying to
work through Congress so it'll be a very
interesting thing because Republicans
will feel much more in power and they'll
start to push back on the president's
agenda really interesting let's just
whilst we've got you here in London more
touch on on 2024. firstly I mean there's
been so much focus on the Republican
nominee on the Democrat side is is it
100 lock that it's going to be present
by yes 100 Larkin just two weeks ago the
president had his big donors in because
he realizes that if he can move very
quickly to get a billion dollars and
that's a billion with a B locked up soft
circled as they like to say in the money
world he can move very quickly to making
sure that no one there's Robert Kenny Jr
that's out there is really marginal but
if he gets a billion dollars he moves
very quickly but the funny thing is if
you think about the Republicans in the
way that DeSantis had a disastrous uh
opening announcement you know on Twitter
on Twitter and this really shows that
he's not ready for prime time in a lot
of circles and this is obviously what
Donald Trump does very well he knows how
to play to the media he knows how to
orchestrate victim minutes so this
really undercut DeSantis although he did
raise I think 10 or 12 million dollars
in one day on the back of this debacle
so you think Trump will be the
Republican nominee I think right now
looks likely that he'll be there the
Republican nominee he's probably the
only guy who can't beat Biden just the
funny thing is uh DeSantis maybe some
others could be more of a threat to the
president just sorry one final thing
going back you mentioned RFK Jr that a
lot of people here might not know as
well I mean he's not thought to be a
genuine challenge but he is polling
interestingly in double-digit
percentages low double digit percentages
could that be an issue for Biden because
it will make him have to join the debate
stage earlier in the year through the
primary season and that might expose
perhaps some of his frailties or is that
not really an issue do you think Biden
sails through and the first debate will
be in you know a month before the
election yeah I think number there's two
reasons why he's pulling well number one
he is a Kennedy so there's still
Nostalgia for there the other thing is
he's running on a populist campaign
right he's running on issues that people
are talking about and care about so
those are the two things I think if
Biden gets a billion dollars this is
really not going to be a factor I think
Kennedy is maybe looking at the next
shot just as DeSantis right he's 44. you
run in America you run to lose to run to
win right so DeSantis could be setting
up for a bank shot as well Morris uh
great to see you thanks so much for
joining us thank you more free partner
at active write some uh other stories uh
now only a third of UK Hospitality
businesses uh say they're optimistic
about their future because of high
energy prices and Rising food costs pubs
bars and restaurants say there Energy
prices have surged by an average of 81
over the past year on top of rising food
and wage bills industry bosses are
warning that some venues will be forced
to shut for good unless cost pressures
starts to ease soon
meager savings rates offered by some
High Street banks are short-changing
customers by hundreds of pounds every
single year that's according to research
done by the consumer Group which who are
encouraging people to shop around for
the best possible deal
right his countries struggle to reduce
their carbon emissions carbon removal is
seen as key to helping to limit global
warming to 1.5 degrees it includes
directly extracting carbon dioxide from
the air as well as planting more trees
to absorb it the tech startup curate has
just secured 5.3 million pounds of
pre-seed funding develop its platform
which buys carbon removal credits and
joining me now is Mata krupinska a
co-founder and chief executive for of
curate and UK lead at Google startups
Google for startups thanks so much for
joining us very good see thank you so
much for having me so so uh you've
announced this deal uh raising 5.3
million pounds so it's a huge congrats
on that but just first of all talk us
through what exactly curate does what
was the service that you offer yes so as
you very rightly pointed out it is
absolutely Paramount that we reduce
carbon emissions as much as possible and
actually UK is a very exciting place
because we have the first legal
definition of NetZero which means as an
organization you have to reduce
emissions by 90 and then remove the rest
and we are helping with that last bit
with the removing the rest a lot of us
have heard about carbon offset a lot of
it is about protecting existing carbon
sinks like forests or maybe moving to
sustainable fuels a carbon removal is
when you actively sequest the carbon out
of the atmosphere and that might be
through different methods from
engineering methods like director
capture to working with soil carbon for
instance so what we do is we look at all
of the global providers of carbon
removal we've developed our own
proprietary process to review their
impact integrity and scalability and
then we buy those carbon removals pull
them into a portfolio that's de-risked
and always looks at all of the methods
in the round and then we sell that onto
clients who wish to remove the residual
carbon emissions so that's really
interesting so I mean it's not so much
advising a company if you start doing
this in your process you'll emit less
carbon it's it's kind of a carbon
trading credit platform indeed and it's
I have to again say it's incredibly
important that organizations do their
carbon accounting properly it's a very
very complex process in their
organizations that really specialize in
doing this but where we come in is once
you've got your carbon carbon accounting
done and you know that you're left with
a residual of say a thousand tons or a
hundred thousand tons in fact when it
becomes really really exciting because
actually part of the challenge of carbon
removals is that there isn't very much
stock of high quality Supply today and
these are clients we are particularly
excited to work with because then with
those opportunities with those
transactions we can go and help set up
more carbon removal Supply that will get
us to 10 billion tons that we need by
2050. so the ipcc talks about carbon
removal being required to the tune of 10
billion tons by 2050 you've got a huge
industry to build here and so there's
been quite a few full storms not just in
recent years but but the last 15 years
in terms of the carbon offset and carbon
credits Market why why is now different
why do you think this Market will really
take hold like everything it's not just
about the idea if it doesn't face a
financial reality it kind of Fades away
definitely and I think one of the things
we really have to try and do is to clean
up the language so we have a dual
structure curate is the start of the
text artem that I'm the CEO of we also
have a sister NGO called rethinking
removals and we're talking about Market
making for carbon removals it's a new
category and we need to clean up the
language a lot of the carbon offsets
would be what you call a protection
credit or a reduction credit so you're
reducing how much carbon is being
emitted or you're protecting an existing
carbon sink a carbon removal is a
different type of asset it's a different
type of credit so only about four
percent of all carbon offsets actually
remove carbon and again we're going back
to the ipcc report that talks about how
we need to maximally reduce emissions
but we've already left it too late so we
need to build those time machines so to
speak to actively sequester carbon from
the atmosphere and store it away safely
for hundreds and thousands of years and
and just finally uh what was to go here
I'm interested how you found going
through this fundraising round I mean of
course public markets have fallen from
their peaks a few years ago and there's
a lot of talk of private markets still
having quite a correction to come do you
think valuations are significantly down
to had you done this a couple years ago
was it a fairly easy process I mean I
suppose we are incredibly lucky that my
co-founders and I have had a lot of
experience in the space Dr Gregory
Walker our chief scientist then Mark
Stevenson who advised amongst others the
ministry of the fence on that xero and
myself this is not my first rodeo unless
you pointed out I have had previously
both started companies and led Google
for startups that sort of put us in the
right place I suppose to be able to
secure a very healthy funding round that
we believe is going to lead us to all
the future success broadly if we talk
about markets I suppose climate Tech is
still a very interesting category it's a
fast-growing market and there are some
exceptional uh exceptional foundries in
this space so when it comes to climate
Tech broadly I'm very optimistic Mata
thanks so much for joining us thank you
so much much appreciated
still to come here on uh Ian King live
we'll take a look at how Global markets
are starting off this morning we'll be
right back
[Music]
thank you
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is this guy used
daily podcast Alex Crawford joining us
now from Ukraine their personal
possessions are all scattered around the
place our economics and data editor Ed
Callaway try and make sense of at the
big numbers for us things can change
incredibly quickly that's what they have
done so by the end we'll hopefully all
understand what's going on in the world
just that little better available
whenever you get your podcasts
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
we're normal six stations yes come down
I'm Stuart Ramsey and I'm Sky's Chief
correspondent you either live and
recover or you die
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's have a look at how the markets are
performing first the Asian uh markets
seeing as you can see uh Australia down
0.1 percent uh Hong Kong is up it had
been down earlier in the session so a
sort of slight Improvement through the
Asian trading session of course worth
pointing out that Chinese equities which
ripped high late last year and in the
early part of this year have pulled back
significantly in recent uh weeks and
months as fears emerge about quite how
strong their post reopening uh pandemic
reopening bounce back will be let's have
a look at European trade similar store
in terms of opening a little bit soft
and improving a bit through the session
France is still lower but hardly lower
down just 0.1 percent it had been down
uh close to one percent early in the
session the ftse is uh just lower itself
uh with everything else mixed so a
little bit of gains there for Germany as
you can see there the ftse is down 0.1
0.2 percent in terms of the sectors real
estate and media are the best before
forming whereas food and Beverages and
oil and gas are the worst performing
sectors so let's have a look at
currencies the dxy the dollar Index are
hitting a two-month high of late uh
partly on the hopes of course around the
debt ceiling partly of course on
interest rate expectations uh but uh
that just reversing the last couple of
months uh the decline that the dollar
had had over the prior uh four to five
months you can see Sterling against the
dollar at about 124 this morning finally
oil prices
I was seeing WTI at around 72 and Brent
at 75.30 both are down as you can see
though this morning uh down about 2.2
percent now for Brent so our price is
just worsening through the course uh of
the morning uh 71 for WTI and 75 for
Brent let's get more uh on the market so
guys ahead of uh UK activities for
investec wealth and investment uh great
to see you guys thanks so much for for
joining us first let's just um touch on
the the big topic of the week or
certainly was last week and maybe it
won't be any more but on this hopes for
a deal for the U.S debt ceiling where do
you think markets are relative to that
if a deal now gets over the line is
there much upside still to come or or is
the other the other direction more
profound if a deal falls apart which
isn't likely at this point would you see
a big collapse in Market I think you're
right that sentiment will take a big hit
if we saw you know the deal fail to get
through Congress over the course of this
week particularly with that X date of
the 5th of June looming that's now known
very very close before the US starts to
benefit some serious uh decisions about
how they spend their money if they can't
agree a new debt ceiling but no I think
if if the deal does pass in a fairly
orderly way through Congress this week
you'll see a little bit of a relief
around in the market certainly at the
shorter end of that U.S fixed interest
Market t-bills where some of the yields
have been very elevated uh over the last
couple of weeks but as you saw from the
market reaction today yeah the Market's
fairly non-plussed by what was a very
positive development over the weekend I
wanted to touch a little bit on the
Outlook specifically for for UK equities
at the moment I mean for a long time
it's been a case of you know the US is
where the growth is perhaps Asia and
other Emerging Markets are are where
longer term opportunities was are we
seeing now the UK in a relative sense
more attractive versus the rest of the
world than it has been for quite some
time you know the growth Outlook is not
fantastic but it's at least turning a
corner and improving a little bit Yeah
Yeah indeed and the you know the
likelihood of a significant recession
both in the UK actually and in Europe
this year progresses has been reduced
and now some forecasters not expecting
the UK to enter recession this year yeah
what the UK stock market has really
compared certainly to the US is a huge
compelling valuation story
you know the UK Market as a whole trades
on much less demanding valuations than
the US market and even if you compare
light for like companies between the UK
and the US the UK names are trading on a
big discount so yes we'd expect to see
you know ongoing inbound interest from
International investors perhaps
International acquirers uh we're no
strangers to m a uh from overseas
investors you know the dollar relatively
strong against the pound UK assets
trading cheaply it wouldn't be
surprising to see a bit more M A coming
into the UK Market but yes with the
economic backdrop uh looking less bad
let's put it like that I think the
investment case of the UK does still
stack up essentially you say like for
like comparisons because I guess the key
sector where you can't make like for
like comparisons is is Tech because the
UK hasn't enjoyed the same Innovation
over the last two decades as the U.S
just touch on that uh for us that this
surge year to date that just a handful
of enormous U.S tech companies has had
and whether you think that is a good
sign for the US market or a bad sign and
just further than that if you did
eventually see a big correction in U.S
indices would that drag down the ftse
100 or given this valuation difference
could it could it hold up I think if you
were to see something the last Point U.S
marketing equities and U.S indices sell
off it will probably be led by that same
cohort of Mega cap companies that have
led the index higher you know the fact
that the NASDAQ is up nearly 25
year-to-date far outstripping the s p uh
just shows you how significant you know
the trillion dollar Club of uh companies
has been in leading the US market higher
yeah what could change that narrative
you know perhaps the higher interest
rate environment uh in the US yeah
certainly in the market after the
regional banking crisis in the US had
been pretty confident in anticipating
you know has been very close to pqs
rates and some quite aggressive Cuts
coming through later this year that
narrative has now Unwound of the
economic data in the US remains fairly
robust the employment data is still very
good and as we saw on Friday that
inflation print uh still running hot in
the US as well it probably means that
the FED has got you know a couple more
weight moves in them and certainly
expectations for the back end of the
year when the market had been pricing
and rates falling back to four and a
half percent or so you know now looks
very optimistic guy listen thanks so
much for joining us much appreciated
so come here on Ian King live what goes
around uh comes back around why flip
phones are experiencing a surging demand
we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back earlier this month the head
of the London Stock Exchange Julia
hoggett called for company bosses in the
UK to be paid more in line with other
countries particularly the US in order
to attract and retain the best talent
well now a survey of non-executive
directors has found that the issue of
pay may be harming growing companies in
particular let's talk now to the co-head
of corporate finance at fincap for
Christopher raggett thanks so much for
for joining us Christopher it's it's a
really interesting report that you guys
have been doing so just talk us through
the the key takeaways from your analysis
sure um so what we wanted to look at was
the attraction of human capital into the
markets obviously there's a lot of Naval
gazing going on at the moments in public
markets particularly there are nine
separate task forces that have been set
up by government and uh and Industry
alone none of them looking at human
capital so what we wanted to do is
examining examine if the public markets
were attracting the right talents as
well
um and what we've found frankly is that
it's not particularly when it comes to
smaller or growing companies and I mean
the key findings from the survey were
that 61 of non-executives had turned
down a role because they felt that the
the time commitment wasn't reflected in
in what they were being paid
um but also that 88 of them found that
the the role of growing companies was
either different or significantly more
onerous than larger companies
and so your report is focused as I
mentioned on the intro in non-executive
directors who do tend to have to be uh
brought in from the outside as as
opposed to Executive roles often often
promoted
um from within do you think it's a
simple case of offering them more money
or or is it more nuanced than that as
you're sort of suggesting that perhaps
the responsibilities are more than what
they might have expected for a non-exec
role
yeah it is definitely more nuanced I
don't think we're arguing or anyone
would argue that with the cost of living
crisis going on the non-executive
directors should necessarily be paid
more it's more about having Creative
Solutions around how they're paid and
not having a box sticking exercise where
you can't use those Creative Solutions
because you'll be voted against at your
AGM and so that's what we're advocating
rather than just plainly saying more
pain
and and uh in your analysis were there
differences between the biggest
companies versus the smallest companies
who who's struggling the most to attract
uh the right type of non-execs
it's it's definitely the smaller
companies that we're focusing on the
growth the growth area of the market
um I mean the the strictures are the
same whether you're
um big small growing or whatever
um you still have the same
responsibilities as non-exec and as an
exec
um but in essence um with a number of
high-profile should become failures on
on the public markets the scrutiny that
non-executives are under particularly in
the growth area seems to be that much
higher
it's interesting that that's a sort of
negative or a challenge I mean again to
the comparison to the us obviously uh
clearly uh the pay is lower for all
sorts of reasons but equally British
boards tend to have a little bit more
power you don't have as many chairman
and CEO roles merged where it's a sort
of uh yes sir yes man yes woman approach
that could or perhaps should by the
right type of uh hard work could be seen
as a positive more responsibility but
more power but are you saying that's
been seen as a negative because people
do just want to have a sort of easy job
if they take a non-executive role now I
think that's fair I don't think it's
fair that anyone would take on
non-executive role for an easy life um
because it's not and that's what the
report's showing us
um but and I totally I don't disagree
that it's a privilege to be on the
public market you know you're
essentially saying that this company is
well enough governed that all in Sundry
can buy those buy their shares and say
that that is definitely a privilege but
I think you what we are doing at the
moment is that the the governance codes
were intended to be comply or explained
particularly the excellent qca um
corporate governance code and I think
now with the the the pendulum has swung
so far the other way that actually has
become comply or else and the
flexibility that's baked into those
codes just isn't being used so we're not
saying that anyone shouldn't be under
scrutiny or that you shouldn't you
should denigrate the public markets but
what we are saying is that there should
be some more flexibility around how
boards operate and how they're
remunerated so that you can actually
Avail yourselves of what the
government's codes are saying because
that's definitely not happening at the
moment and Christopher what is the
advice on how they're renumerated I mean
is it more stock and more
performance-based pay or what
I think so but it has to be um bespoke
ultimately particularly in the Growth
Company world where the challenges are
different and the challenges are nuanced
themselves so I think what what we're
advocating for is a bespoke approach
where just because someone's getting
options or whatever doesn't actually
stymie their independence what we're
saying is that as long as it's right for
all stakeholders in the business there
should be a more flexible approach
around stock options and incentivizing
non-executive directors to give up their
time their experience their mentorship
their guidance
um in a different way
Christopher ragett thanks so much for
joining us thank you
now the Finnish mobile phone maker Nokia
is relaunching one of its classic flip
phones so citing a surge in interest by
gen Z's and Millennials the Nokia 2660
flip phone was first launched back in
2007 a bit of nostalgia for us here and
is now back on the market with Nokia
saying so-called dumb phones are in fact
growing in popularity as people seek to
limit their screen time well I'm joined
now uh here in Studio by Lars
silberbauer the chief marketing officer
at Nokia mobiles
um thanks so much for joining us thank
you for having us so so this is really
interesting so I mentioned that you're
saying people want to limit their screen
time totally get that but are you saying
that Millennials and gen z's are leading
this this move themselves rather than
being told to By Boring parents and and
the like definitely I think I think we
all know that that generation is not
just doing what they're told by their
parents and we see this trend starting
in the U.S really starting last year we
can see that we really have doubled our
market share
um over the years and in flip phones we
see it starting in the US and now coming
to Europe with really Genesis leading
this trend but it's a it's a trend we
also see in the older Generations really
that people want to take ownership of
their own Digital Life and want to limit
their their screen time so so again
really interesting that that this is
happening or you guys are pushing it to
happen via a new hardware setup by a new
flip phone I mean has it got a different
operating system different functionality
inside that that does lead to that
headline dumb phones being applicable
label or can it once you open it can it
do everything that that an iPhone or a
well be a different operating system the
the best Android phones can can do I
think like these flip phones are of
course like it's a it's 25 years since
we launched the first split phone and
these phones can you can call you can
text and you can play Snake and then you
can get a lot more time to actually
enjoy life and I think that's the
important part so the important part is
not really what the phone can do the
important part is what it really allows
you to do and that is that you realize
that you actually are being caught up
with constantly being notified getting
put in a social media posts and really
being dragged into digital so these
phones are actually a way to realize
that you can actually have a much more
enjoyable moments in life than on the
phone I'm not sure snake would return it
to my phone would limit my screen time
and it takes me back anyway so so what's
the operating system on this is it an
Android operating system or is it again
a Nokia Symbian uh developed system so
it's not a smartphone so it's a feature
phone so it's a classical operating
system on a feature phone so it has all
of those those traditional things on a
feature phone because I'm interested
therefore that that you're you're
flipping back to the idea that Hardware
can drive perhaps Nokia to to have a
significant foothold again in the the
not smartphone in the handset Market
which of course it used to be number one
it felt Fell From Grace and largely I
think it's fair to say it felt From
Grace because of software it didn't
develop a very user-friendly software
like apple did with iOS or like Google
did with Android does Nokia hope weirdly
that going back to Old less impressive
software can give it a strong position
in the hardware Market once again I
think first and foremost important to
say that we are already selling millions
of phones every month so it's not a it's
a fairly big number of phones that are
being being sold by by Nokia so we're
not a small player in that sense
especially not in the future phone
market and I think when it comes to
smartphone we would also love to sell
your smartphone but the reason why we're
introducing flip phones is really
because we want people to realize that
we can see this trend and we're
answering this trend about people
wanting to take ownership after Digital
Life so typically you would say like
your smartphone is a digital assistant
but sometimes it do become a digital
dictator and that's really what the what
the trend is about and that's what we're
trying to to help people to to to to to
realize and really experience and just
finally what are these a lot cheaper
than a Samsung Galaxy or an iPhone and
they are a lot cheaper they're around 55
pounds so a lot cheaper than the normal
so we don't think that people would
switch from smartphones to to a flip
phone but they might add a flip phone to
to their range of devices I think it's
very interesting thanks so much for
joining us thank you very much
appreciate
and that's the breaking news uh the
chair of the covert inquiry has granted
an extension for the government to
present its evidence the deadline has
been moved from 4 pm today to 4 P.M this
Thursday the 1st of June so a few days
extension there
I still come here on uh Ian King live
I'll be speaking to the chief executive
of Hollywood Bowl about its latest
results and the popularity of 10 Pin
bowling here in the UK we'll be right
back
thank you
[Music]
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is this guy used
daily podcast Alex Crawford joining us
now from Ukraine their personal
possessions are all scattered around the
place our economics and data editor Ed
Conway try him extensive at the big
numbers for us things can change
incredibly quickly that's what they have
done so by the end we'll hopefully all
understand what's going on in the world
just that little better available
whatever you get your podcasts
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
for a number six version let's just come
down
I'm Stuart Ramsey and I'm Skye's Chief
correspondent you either live and
recover or you die
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Global insight made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back uh time now for a look at
this morning's uh business Pages uh
let's have a look at some of the key
stories well the financial times leads
with news that labors planning to Force
Major landowners to sell off plots
cheaply if the party takes power in an
effort to cut the costs of building new
homes so let's have a look also at the
telegraph uh they are reporting the
Labor's plan for Pension funds is under
attack which schroed is saying fund
managers should not be inhibited by
government interference interestingly on
that topic in the time Simon French from
Pamela Jordan highlights three reforms
which he says could transform
perceptions of the stock market an
interesting article about why the
difference in the UK and the U.S
valuations continues to last since
impossible reforms with me to discuss
all of this is the business editor of
the sun Ashley Armstrong Ashley great to
see you why don't we touch on that that
story that kind of crossed the last two
the Telegraph and the time story that we
picked out first because clear really
there's a big valuation gap between the
UK and the US and everyone's kind of
trying to wonder how it can be closed
one of the areas is you know this idea
of forcing uh Pension funds or domestic
investors to buy more UK stocks relative
to International interesting to me in
the Simon French article is the idea
that particularly the UK public Pension
funds should be forced to do that and
it's not as unfair because they tend to
be defined benefit schemes so the
beneficiaries have a set amount of money
they'll get as opposed to the idea of
restricting them from buying something
that might grow faster than a UK Equity
yeah no I think it kind of um is very
much bringing together all those debates
at the moment why is the London Stock
Exchange flailing in comparison to the
US why are so many British companies
choosing the US why is the liquidity not
deep enough in this country and I think
as as we've seen in the telegraph as
well Schroeder's hitting out I had the
boss of pension B we've had the boss of
Aviva all kind of criticizing Labor's
plans to create this 50 billion super
growth fund with our Pension funds
because because essentially our pensions
are us it's interesting that the
government wants to use them as a piggy
bank to kind of fund the UK economy and
Simon French who's a brilliant Economist
commentator you know the things that
he's pulling out about the defined
benefit
um schemes well very few people have DBS
anymore that was kind of of yesteryear
but the idea is is that it's you know
kind of a set guaranteed pension payment
so there's lower risk to you or I if we
were to have one rather than actually
somebody kind of investing in something
through Scottish widows or AXA or the
other Pension funds and not being able
to see exactly where they're investing
um it is it's definitely a debate that's
going to roll on because there's this
big argument about you know where should
our pensions be going should they be in
going into UK infrastructure that will
ultimately help the economy
interestingly I think the biggest factor
which can't be tweaked around the edges
with policy is the outlook for the ftse
100 versus the S P 500 and actually how
hard for it to be as bad as it was for
the last decade and maybe in a relative
sense we'll be turning the corner there
with uh UK companies doing a little bit
better as they did last year uh let's
touch on another story that in pretty
much every paper's non-business section
and my question to you is whether it
should be in the business section as
well and and the issues going on this
morning uh on on ITV the share price for
ITV this morning opened down a percent
it's now back to flat or or so do you
think all of that kind of stuff is a is
a threat to the business model and uh
when we look at the the sort of
five-year tenure of Carolyn McCall how
how has she done it overall yeah well I
mean the sun has really been leading the
way under Hull kind of this morning Saga
so I don't think that'll be kind of
jostling with them for for it to be on
the business page just yet but I think
it is interesting with Carolyn McCall
you know in December she very much said
that she was halfway through her job and
she said she said that privately one of
the key things that she's got in her
defenses is that she has has seen this
itvx you know their big streaming
platform and really doubled down on that
as a kind of UK Challenger for free
streaming which is particularly
interesting given that Netflix and all
the rest of them are hiking the prices
for the subscription
um it is a difficult time especially
when ITV bills itself so much on the
content and the talent that it has and
this morning was a huge show for it it's
it's not made it any easier for Carolyn
I would say she's very respected through
her time in EasyJet but she's also been
there five years the share price is down
almost half since she took over that's
not all her fault a lot of that was the
covert lockdowns and all of that kind of
UK sell-off that we saw but it doesn't
make it any easier well Ashley thanks so
much for joining us this morning we're
tight on time so sadly don't get to the
third story but I'm sure we'll have
another chance soon thanks so much
Ashley Armstrong business editor at the
Sun
now with many children off a school for
half term families will be looking for
ways to entertain them this week which
means Leisure operators such as bowling
alleys will no doubt be busier than
usual well Hemel Hempstead based
Hollywood Bowl runs 64 bowling alleys
across the UK and this morning it
reported pre-tax profits of 26.7 million
for the six months to March 30 31st down
from 33.4 million a year ago but with a
record first off revenue of 110 million
pounds uh well joining us now is the
chief executive for Stephen Byrne
Stephen thanks so much for for joining
us I want to get into the um
nitty-gritty of these numbers in a
moment but but big picture question
first I mean do you think we're back to
the ideal balance that you saw
pre-pandemic of people's Leisure
spending being as much in person out of
the home interactions as uh staying at
home spending
yeah I think things are starting to
certainly come back to a little bit like
they were pre-pandemic
um I mean the pandemic did accelerate a
number of trends that were already under
development as people were already
looking for spending their money more on
experiences rather than things and then
being forced to stay at home is such a
protracted period of time meant that
when we were allowed to go out and do
things um you know we we did them to
excess so I think we are starting to see
things return a little bit back to the
way that they were pre-pandemic albeit
on a slightly higher base
that said is it is it being offset by
the the cost of living pressures and a
tepid economy if we use that word
um that's not actually something that
we're seeing in our sector we are very
fortunate in the 74 of our revenues are
subjected to the inflationary cost
pressures so 50 of our revenue is
bowling and that's 100 gross profit and
24 of our revenues come from the
amusement machines that are on a fixed
cost
um or fixed Revenue share
um the remainder which is food and
beverage
um is subject to quite significant cost
pressures
um but the offset that we've been doing
regarding our pricing which has helped
drive volume has helped us maintain our
profits actually as you've seen from the
numbers this time around that whilst
profits are down on a lifelike basis um
versus last year it's not true lifelike
because of the uh seven million pounds
of um uh reduced rate of vat and rate
benefits that we got from the government
during the um during that covert
affected period so on a normalized basis
revenues and profits are significantly
up actually up over 20 versus the same
period last year
how popular is 10 Pin bowling in the UK
and and how penetrated is it you know
relative to the us or something do you
think there's significant grounds for
expansion here in this in this country
well I mean 98 of the UK population have
at some point been bowling in their
lives but it's not something that you do
on a really frequent or regular basis
like you might see over um over in the
U.S
um the actual size of the UK bowling
Market has stayed pretty static over the
last sort of 10 15 years around about
340 polling sites in the UK and we
believe there's opportunity for about
another 20 Hollywood Bowl centers in the
UK which is why we turned our attention
to North America last year acquiring the
Splitsville and Striker Brands out in
Canada we've actually nearly doubled the
size of that business since the
acquisition in in May of last year out
in Canada
Stephen Burns sir chief executive of
Hollywood Bowl thanks so much for
joining us very much
foreign
before we go let's uh just uh recap for
you how the markets uh are looking we
started the Futures on European trade
higher uh when we opened it it was uh
lower with the French Market down as
much as a percent at one point but we've
steadily improved since the open now
you've got Germany up 0.5 France down
now only a quarter of a percent Italy's
High by nearly half a percent 4100 is
down uh but uh only about a third of one
percent uh Sterling this morning uh as
you can see here is up a nice half
percent a decent move to 124 the broader
dollar Index has had a decent bounce
back on hopes of a U.S debt deal that
does it for Ian King live today much
more coverage uh coming up with Kimberly
Leonard uh on Sky News here next
foreign
[Music]